you're watching swipe coming up on this
week's show driverless cars the latest
on one of the most exciting emerging
technologies assisted driving I keep my
foot off the brake to see how this car
intervenes and if there's a gamer in
your life we might just have some
Christmas list ideas in our games review
welcome to swipe there's a theme to this
week's show it's cars driverless ones
you see we realized autonomous vehicles
get talked about a lot but we're in
danger of losing track of all the
developments a little bit later aren't
we trying out some auto brake technology
but before then Stu has been taking a
look at just how road-ready driverless
cars really are if the push for
driverless cars is a race several
winners could cross the finish line
you've seen the product launches but
behind the scenes what problems are
driverless car specialists trying to
solve I would say the biggest challenge
is on the testing side of things if you
think of the scenarios in which the
driverless car may be put there's so
many things and random events that can
go on how can you design and write the
software to handle all of those events
most of them come in the unforeseen a
lot of testing is being done in
simulators Google alone covers the
equivalent of three million miles
everyday in virtual testing the
company's vehicles are also out in the
real world this is how Google's
driverless cars see our roads and they
may have come across the ultimate
unforeseen scenario our vehicles were
driving through Mountain View and this
is what we encountered this is a woman
in an electric wheelchair
chasing a duck in circles on the road
now it turns out there is nowhere in the
DMV handbook that tells you how to deal
with that what our vehicles were able to
encounter that slow down and drive
safely
that's the head of Google's driverless
cars project who calls the human
motorist a bug that needs to be fixed
that's because around 94% of road
accidents can be blamed on human error
perhaps you grudgingly accept that
driverless cars are going to become
commonplace in the near future but that
you won't want one well that's not the
plan letting somebody loose in a car to
drive themselves I think eventually will
be will be considered to be not worth
the risk and I would expect that as
autonomous vehicles become widespread
that it become a privilege to to drive a
car but much the same as you might have
a motorbike for fun or even a horse for
fun and you'd have a car that you took
out for a spin and there be places that
people knew you were going to do that
and they wouldn't go there unless they
were willing to take the risks if you be
on the road a recent survey found 39% of
people in the UK would consider using a
self-driving vehicle that number rises
to 62% among young professionals living
in cities driverless cars seems to be
the next step to make people's lives
that much easier driving will maintain
its its place in the hearts of a lot of
people but in terms of the more boring
side such as dropping the children off
at school or going to the supermarket
automated driving or take over because
nobody loves doing that part of driving
the pilot projects continue with
problems to solve around security and
insurance but experts say you could be
using a fully autonomous car as soon as
2035 Stuart Duggan Sky News Delta car on
swipe an open world's first in our games
review Holly looks at Just Cause 3 and
Xenoblade Chronicles X but first here's
a roundup of some of this week's other
tech news Samsung's Galaxy s6 edge has
picked up more prizes it's been named
smartphone of the year and gadget of the
year at the stuff Magazine Awards Apple
won three prizes although the iPhone
missed out I see you stand if you've
ever wanted to feel like a Shakespearean
actor on the stage a new projects from
Google could make that happen
the company's been working with cultural
institutions like the Royal Shakespeare
Company you can now see interact
360 degree views of performances like
this famous speech from Henry the Farage
cry God for Harry introducing uberpool
uber has a new ride-sharing service for
Londoners the company says uber pool
saves you 25% on each journey by pairing
you up with someone going the same way
you only pay for your part of the
journey and if you're worried about
privacy only your first nail is shared
with the other passenger and a new
gadget that lets you interact with your
pets while you're away from home has
come to the UK the pet see treat cam
allows you to see and speak to your pet
remotely you can even give them a treat
and take photos to share on social media
now it doesn't matter how techy your car
is accidents can still happen which is
why I've been having a go on some Auto
break technologies what do we do how
does this work ok so we're starting a
Volvo v60 which is got city safety
system fitted to it and that uses a
sensor behind the screen here to scan
the road ahead looking for objects that
are going to cause you a problem if
you're not paying attention to the road
so these are things where it will break
for you if you're not braking right and
this is our target so we're driving it a
balloon car today this is our target
you're going to drive it at about 10
miles an hour and act as if you're not
paying it in okay right here we go I'm
just gonna take my feet off the pedal
completely ready
that feels so strange I just want to
break it feels really really unnatural
what would happen if I needed to swerve
because sometimes you don't just need to
brake you need to swerve to avoid
something that's right so what this car
does it also gives you a warning so if
you're traveling and there's something
in front of you it gives you a warning
first which gives you time to then look
around and see if you can take action to
avoid the collision or if you don't take
still don't take any action the warning
was it that was so that was the red
light that popped up on the on the
screen and also that was the sound that
you heard as well just before the brakes
came in and so if there's time for you
to avoid it you can then avoid it if not
the car brake for you is there any
scenario where the auto brake does not
kick in or is it always there it's
always there but it won't kick in if it
thinks you're paying attention so he
thinks you're in the loop and
controlling the vehicle so if you're
steering and you're braking you're
accelerating yourself so we can feel me
steering and it knows I'm wide awake and
paying attention hopefully if you're if
you're not steering it thinks all
there's a problem here I'm gonna brake
for you this is a traditional car it's
not a driverless car but this is
driverless technology so is this just a
way of kind of making people more
familiar with driverless technologies so
that one day we might all be in
driverless cars and that will seem a
little bit more natural that's right I
mean this is one of the first
technologies in sort of the driverless
suite of technologies if you like so
this is it's almost like drip feeding
into into cars the sort of technologies
in future will be commonplace and
actually do all of the driving for you
but this is sort of the first building
block of those technologies it's
December which means it's nearly
Christmas which means it's nearly time
for presents so in this week's games
review we're taking a look at some of
the latest releases in case you need any
gift ideas
buildings bases and gas stations Just
Cause 3 is all about blowing things up
in his creative way as possible so you
make your way around the Mediterranean
island of Medici and you've liberate
towns and military bases away from evil
you know dictator you know the story
isn't gonna blow anyone's mind but it's
very pretty setting it's an you know the
kind of blue seas and the fields full of
flowers are quite a nice kind of an
antidote to all the chaos going on the
game enables you to create all this
chaos we're giving you a number of
gadgets vehicles and weapons and they
are a lot of fun however you do have to
upgrade them and sometimes it can be a
little bit annoying when you just want
to you know have fun and use whatever is
given to you but you have to wait and
unlock things the missions aren't great
the story missions and the challenges
which you need to do to unlock these
things can be a little bit repetitive
they get quite boring quite quickly the
game relies on you being able to make
your own fun and be creative however it
doesn't it doesn't push you in that way
enough sometimes and if you don't have
that creative spark then you might get
bored quite quickly Tom Clancy's Rainbow
six siege is a first-person shooter and
along with the previous games in the
series it's a lot kind of heavier and
slower a lot more power to it than than
other games such as Cod or halo about 4
shots will kill you and you can't
regenerate health so it's quite a
difficult game and because of the
mechanics that it has in the main mode
you either play in an attacking team or
defending team and you have kind of
items such as drones which you use to
Scout and you know map locations or you
have to put up barricades and defend
yourself so it requires you to be quite
tactical and to think very tactically
now the only problem is if you're
playing offline there's not a lot here
the AI enemy AI in offline mode is quite
it's not great you know they just kind
of stand around and it only runs about
30 frames per second and it could feel a
bit jarring however if you do have that
group of friends or you like playing
online with a Mike there is a lot to be
found in the game
so Xenoblade Chronicles X is an
absolutely epic game it's based in a
world of mirror and is absolutely
stunning it's full of all these kind of
alien creatures and amazing environments
but it's absolutely huge it can be quite
daunting though if you're not familiar
with LPGs particularly Japanese RPGs
there's a lot of stats color
coordination a lot of numbers flying
about the screen there's a lot to get
your head around even just learning how
to figure out the map is quite an effort
in itself and it takes a while to get
going you know you need to put in about
20 hours before the story and the game
really kicks off and lets you kind of
explore and do your own thing however if
you do have the time and the effort put
into this game you are rewarded one of
the best RPGs on the Wii U it's
incredibly detailed the combat is very
fun and has a lot to it there's a lot to
really sink your teeth into you
so if you do have the time available I
would highly recommend Centerplate
Chronicles X Square rave is a game
developed by Adam hey it's on iOS and
it's a very fun little game they blend
some of the gameplay elements from River
River matching games and snake so you
have to control a white square and as
you move the white square around the
grid it leaves a trail behind it and you
can't crash into the trail you've got to
put it over blue squares before a bar on
the screen gets to be over under the
screen the music is really good actually
the whole point is that it's kind of in
time with the music it's kind of electro
rave music it's really enjoyable when
you first look at the game it might be a
little bit confusing you know you think
what are you meant to do however it's
very intuitive once you start you really
get a hang of it very quickly and there
are six levels overall to complete and
you're constantly wanting to beat your
score so although it's very frantic and
it's kind of overwhelming in some points
it's very intuitive and very fun you
know it's very fast-paced and very
addictive actually
that's it for this week's show I'll see
you again next time
bye bye